CTM in focus is what we're calling the
original reporting you'll see only on
CBS this morning
exposing new information on issues that
impact us all today an inside look at
the business of location tracking we're
learning new details about how
advertisers track our location through
our phones and how criminals could
exploit that information more than a
thousand apps reportedly collect
location data fueling an estimated 21
billion dollar market but lawmakers and
some tech leaders argue it must be
regulated Tony Zucco poll obtains some
of the sensitive data thanks to a
whistleblower
Tony good morning good morning here's a
story for you I recently spoke with a
young tech worker whose job it was he
says to buy daily location data on some
80 million Americans he recently quit
that business though telling us the
industry was failing to secure the
information he was afraid to be
recognized on camera but instead he gave
us a list of contacts a we could
experience this secretive trade for
ourselves your submission has been
received over the winter we began
calling emailing send and texting our
way into the location data business so
we're looking for I guess you call
device IDs with lat/long timestamps
location data typically comes from apps
that log the movements of a person's
phone often people aren't even aware of
the terms and conditions of these
programs allow the information to be
collected the data is then sold to
aggregators who in turn sell it to
advertisers looking for consumer trends
I'll send an email that will also call
we wanted to know who else gets ahold of
that information there we go
six major data companies pitched us
their product okay
unaware they were actually talking to a
journalist the bread crumbing effect
what is that one company promised to
track people as often as every seven
seconds another said they could prove
the quality of the data by tracking my
phone still another pledge to deliver
people's location in real time and all
promised information on tens of millions
of phone users every day including at
home with a few emails and a phone call
we got the
sample of data showing the movements of
more than 1500 phones over the course of
a single day in one of the riches if
codes in America Greenwich Connecticut
and the fact that you were able to get
so much data on the American citizens
that live up here is quite disturbing
Adam Scott wants studies big data at the
John Jay College of Criminal Justice he
helped us analyze the risks and a
neighborhood like this one Wow no names
or phone numbers were tied to the data
but it was easy to figure out who each
phone belongs to based on where they
spend their nights here in Greenwich
it's a place that invests heavily in
privacy and security but this data
allowed us to go beyond all that to
follow as people move through the
community and at some of these larger
homes we could even track as people
moved from room to room one phone pinged
in the morning inside a 7 million dollar
mansion the person then visited a
country club before heading downtown and
returning home another phone pings
someone's location 231 times as he or
she left home for an hour to run an
errand this is a very large sample set
Lots want to explain to how this could
be valuable information to a potential
criminal if you're able to monitor your
your target your mark and you're able to
tell when they're driving when they're
not perhaps when they're having an
affair with their mistress it becomes
much easier to take advantage of them
and extort it's compromising information
it's extremely compromising information
but it's perfectly legal no federal law
limits the collection or use of this
data though there have been calls for
regulation in a Time magazine op-ed
Apple CEO Tim Cook called on the feds to
rein in data brokers and allow consumers
to track the transactions that have
bundled and sold their data we wanted to
find out how the people being tracked
feel about all this sure of the to
homeowners we were able to reach one
told us he was alarmed but didn't want
to appear on camera the others reaction
caught us by surprise we want to make
you aware that a phone in this household
is being tracked in real time by a data
location company and we
I invite you two to see the data and
respond if you'd like why would I care
you're not worried about it these phones
are treasure troves want warns many
Americans are overlooking the potential
consequences of sharing their location
data if I followed him down the street
he'd be looking over his shoulder and
eventually he would ask me to stop yeah
but his phone is following him right now
just the same way and sending that data
to some database most likely it is he is
willfully ignoring the security risk and
the privacy risks of carrying the phone
for the convenience it provides him the
things we do for convenience now we
asked executives at eight different
location data companies for an interview
and all eight declined or never got back
to us some told us that they do take
privacy seriously and have safeguards in
place but none was willing to divulge
which apps are selling this data let
alone who's buying the data if you want
to find out how you can adjust your apps
go to your settings in your phone and
there should be a button there where you
can turn off the location services but
of course then a lot of inconvenience
coming your way all right it's so it's
in the privacy section under settings
it's like the last one and then you can
do location services on or off but every
time you use Maps or car service you're
gonna have trouble okay I've tried to
turn it off but then I find myself
forced to kind of turn it back on for
things like that and when you turn it
off are you really turning it off yeah
that's the other question you know I
mean other than with a sledgehammer I'm
thinking there's no I know should we
throw it into the ocean you're fine oh
yeah yeah